GOOD NIGHT FROM WASHINGTON.
SEAN>> WELCOME TO "HANNITY: TRU
VS. THE SWAMP".
WE START WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE FAVORITE CONSPIRACY THEORY
IS DEAD.
THERE WAS NOTHING.
THE WITCH-HUNT IS OVER AND THERE
WILL BE NO FURTHER CHARGES, NO
FURTHER INDICTMENTS AFTER 675
DAYS AND NINE MONTH BEFORE THAT
WITH THE FBI INVESTIGATION.
IN OTHER WORDS, ALMOST THREE
YEARS, TOTAL OF AN INTENSIVE
INVESTIGATION.
ROBERT MUELLER'S REPORT HAS
OFFICIALLY BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, NO MORE
INDICTMENTS, NO COLLUSION
CHARGES WILL BE FILED.
NO OBSTRUCTION CHARGES WILL BE
FILED AND NO CONSPIRACY CHARGES
WILL BE FILED.
THE REPORT DELIVERY SUGGESTS
THAT NO MORE INDICTMENTS ARE
COMING, WHICH WE NOW KNOW IS
TRUE FROM THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE JUST
COMPLETED TWO YEARS OF
INVESTIGATING RUSSIA COLLUSION
WITHOUT ONE COLLUSION-RELATED
INDICTMENT.
NOT EVEN ONE.
INSTEAD, AFTER NEARLY TWO YEARS,
TENS OF MILLIONS OF YOUR TAX
DOLLARS THE MUELLER WITCH-HUNT
ONLY MANAGED TO PROSECUTE, OH, A
FEW PEOPLE FOR PROCESS CRIMES.
LET'S SEE.
PAPADOPOULOS' BIG 12 DAYS IN
JAIL, LYING TO PROSECUTORS.
MILITARY HERO FLYNN HAS NOT BEEN
SENTENCED.
HE NEARLY WENT BANKRUPT BECAUSE
OF MOUNTING LEGAL BILLS.
ADMITTING AND BRAGGING THEY SET
HIM UP, SOMETHING THEY WOULD
NEVER DO IN THE OBAMA OR CLINTON
ADMINISTRATIONS.
AND ROGER STONE IS GOING
BANKRUPT, FACING TRIAL FOR
HARASSING A WITNESS.
COHEN, OF COURSE, WE KNOW HIS
CASE.
OTHER CRIMES RELATED TO BANK
APPLICATION FRAUD AND TAXES.
MANAFORT MAY SPEND THE REST OF
HIS LIFE IN PRISON BECAUSE OF
TAXES AND, AGAIN, LYING ON BANK
LOAN APPLICATIONS.
WHAT DO THEY ALL HAVE IN COMMON?
NOTHING, ZERO TO DO WITH TRUMP,
THE CAMPAIGN OR COLLUSION.
THEY'RE NEVER COMING HERE.
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO BE
EXTRADITED.
MANY WERE RUSSIAN SPIES OR
RUSSIAN BOT COMPANIES.
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO ALLOW
THAT TO HAPPEN.
NONE OF THESE CHARGES INVOLVE
CAMPAIGN COLLUSION WHATSOEVER.
BUT WE HAVE PLENTY OF PRE-DAWN
RAIDS AND GUNS DRAWN AND DOORS
KICKED DOWN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT, SWAT GEAR, HOURS AND
HOURS OF HARDCORE INVESTIGATION,
SCREWS TURNED, LIVES RUINED.
THE MONEY SPENT FOR WHAT?
IT WAS ALWAYS A HOAX, A LIE
CONCEIVED BY HATE, DRIVEN BY
FEAR.
A 22-MONTH WITCH-HUNT, NOT INTO
A CRIME, BUT INTO AN INDIVIDUAL,
A PERSON.
THAT'S DONALD TRUMP, WHO BECAME
PRESIDENT, AND EVERYONE AROUND
HIM.
THIS IS NOT HOW IT'S SUPPOSED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THIS CANNOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
THIS IS DOWNRIGHT DESPICABLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR
CONSTITUTION, EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW, EVERY AMERICAN
TONIGHT SHOULD BE OUTRAGED,
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW DID WE GET
HERE, ESPECIALLY NOW THAT WE
HAVE EVIDENCE OF KNOWN CRIMES,
MASSIVE ABUSE OF POWER, WHICH
WILL BE THE FOCUS OF US IN DAYS
AND MONTHS GOING FORWARD.
NOW, IF THE FULL WEIGHT OF
AMERICA'S JUSTICE SYSTEM WILL BE
USED TO PERSECUTE A SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHEN THEY EVEN TRIED TO SET THE
ELECTION UP FOR THE PERSON THAT
THEY LOVED, WHEN THAT PERSON
SHOULD HAVE BEEN INDICTED, THAT
WOULD MEAN NOBODY IN AMERICA IS
SAFE.
AND STILL, AS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL POINTS OUT, THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WAS NOT HINDERED
IN ANY WAY, NOT BY THE
PRESIDENT, NOT BY ANYBODY, AS IF
BEING PRESIDENT ISN'T HARD
ENOUGH.
THE PRESIDENT WAS FORCED TO DEAL
WITH THIS UNDUE BURDEN OF WHAT
IS IS BASELESS ABSURD
INVESTIGATION THAT ALL BEGAN
BEFORE HE BECAME PRESIDENT IN
JULY OF 2016.
THIS IS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
SPREAD A CONSTANT STEADY STREAM
OF LIES AND MISINFORMATION TO
THE ENTIRE WORLD ABOUT AMERICA'S
SITTING PRESIDENT.
SMALL REMINDER.
OH, AND THIS WILL GET BIG AS THE
DAYS UNFOLD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU TOLD THE WASHINGTON POST
LAST WEEK THAT, QUOTE, THERE'S A
SMELL OF TREASON IN THE AIR WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THOSE
AROUND HIM DURING AN ELECTION
CAMPAIGN CONCLUDE  -- COLLUDED
WITH A HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER TO
UNDERMINE THE BASIS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> DONALD TRUMP NOW SITS AT THE
THRESHOLD OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT WHAT
HE'S DOING IS GIVING AID AND
COMFORT TO THE ENEMY.
>> IT DOES LOOK LIKE COLLUSION.
IT DOES LOOK LIKE HE'S LISTENING
TO PUTIN MORE THAN HE IS
AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE.
>> PUTIN AND HIS ASSOCIATES,
SOMEBODY HAS SOMEBODY ON DONALD
TRUMP.
>> WE'RE HEARING THE NEW WORD.
HE SAID IT WAS TREASON.
>> AND YOU WONDER WHY I CALL
THEM THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA MOB.
THEY WERE JUST FOLLOWING THEIR
ORDERS, AS THEY ALWAYS DO,
TAKING THEIR CUE FROM THE
LEADERS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE OF THAT AS
WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU BELIEVE THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIAN IN THE 2016 CAMPAIGN?
>> YES.
>> I CAN CERTAINLY SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE CAMPAIGN
AND RUSSIA.
>> IT'S BEYOND THE SHADOW OF A
DOUBT TO ME THAT IF THERE WAS
NOT COLLUSION, THERE WAS AT
LEAST THE EFFORT TO CONCLUDE
WITH A FOREIGN POWER.
>> WE SAW COLD, HARD EVIDENCE OF
THE TRUMP EVIDENCE, INDEED, THE
TRUMP FAMILY, EAGERLY INTENDING
TO COLLUDE POSSIBLY WITH RUSSIA,
A HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER, TO
INFLUENCE AMERICAN ELECTIONS,
BECOMING CLEAR WE HAVE SUFFERED
A DESECRATION OF OUR DEMOCRACY
NOT SEEN SINCE WATERGATE.
>> THEY SWALLOWED IT ALL HOOK,
LINE, AND SINKER.
AND TONIGHT, THE ONLY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY SHOCKED AT THE
WITCH-HUNT ARE THOSE ON THE LEFT
WHO AGAIN, ONCE AGAIN, RUSH TO
JUDGMENT, DENIED DUE PROCESS,
PEDDLING A STEADY STREAM OF
DAILY LIES, PROPAGANDA,
MISINFORMATION AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
THEY HATE TRUMP SO MUCH THAT
THEY WERE WILLING TO SUSPEND ANY
AND ALL LOGIC AND CREATE FALSE
HOPES FOR EVERY TRUMP HATER
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT WILL BE A RECKONING.
WE WILL HOLD THESE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS INCLUDES SCHIFF.
HE MIGHT BE THE MOST DETACHED
FROM REALITY.
AFTER A NINE-MONTH INVESTIGATION
FROM THE FBI, A 22-MONTH
INVESTIGATION FROM MUELLER, HE
HAD A BIPARTISAN INVESTIGATION
FROM THE SENATE AND THE HOUSE.
AFTER ALL THESE INVESTIGATIONS
PRIOR TO TODAY TURNED UP ZERO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, SCHIFF
VOWED TO CONTINUE HIS OWN
PERSONAL WITCH-HUNT INTO THE
PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE.
WHY SERVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHEN YOU CAN STAY FOCUSED ON A
CONSPIRACY THEORY?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT ARE THE OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO INVESTIGATE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THE MUELLER REPORT REVEALS?
>> INFORMATION THAT WE'VE
OBTAINED IN OUR INVESTIGATION,
INFORMATION THAT'S BECOME CLEAR
FROM THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION THAT MAY NOT BE
NEATLY SUMMED UP IN A DECISION
OR DISCLOSURE THAT WE DECIDED TO
INDICT A BUT NOT B.
IF THEY'RE NOT ANSWERED, THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER
THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIND THE
TRUTH.
>> SCHIFF CONTINUES TO BE
BLINDED BY HIS RAGE AND HATRED
OF ALL THINGS TRUMP.
AND OF COURSE HE'S RAISING MONEY
OFF OF YOURS TRULY.
SEND OUT FUNDRAISING LETTERS
WITH SEAN HANNITY.
THE MEDIA MOB IS STARTING TO
FACE SOME REALITY.
THEIR FAVORITE CONSPIRACY THEORY
IS DEAD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WOULD BIT THE SMOKING GUN?
WOULD IT GIVE INFORMATION AS TO
CRIMINALITY?
WOULD IT ANSWER THE CORE
QUESTION?
I HAVE TO SAY, I THINK IT'S GOOD
NEWS FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> LET'S BE SPECIFIC.
THIS IS REALLY GOOD NEWS FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE AROUND DONALD
TRUMP.
>> YEAH, THAT NARRATIVE THAT
THAT WAS ALL AN ELABORATE SETUP,
THAT THERE WAS AN ELABORATE
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE, WAITING FOR
THAT LAST ELEMENT, WHICH WAS
AMERICANS COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIANS, IT CLEARLY IS NOT PART
OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S MOVE
FORWARD AT THIS POINT.
>> HE'S BEEN VINDICATED BY THEM.
>> AND THEN HE'S NOT VINDICATED,
EXACTLY.
AS PAMELA'S BEEN REPORTING, THE
LAWYERS ARE --
>> FEELING GOOD.
>> THAT I WOULD BE -- I WOULD BE
VERY HAPPY.
>> YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT THERE IS NO
INDICTMENT THAT ALLEGES ANY
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN ANYONE IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIANS,
THAT VINDICATES THE PRESIDENT TO
SOME DEGREE.
>> YOU SEE THE DISAPPOINTMENT.
OH, IT'S GOT TO BE KILLING THEM.
I CAN ALMOST TASTE THEIR TEARS
FROM HERE.
YEARS AND YEARS OF BREATHLESS
HYSTERIA, LIES PRESENTED AS
FACTS AND TRUTH.
WHAT IF MADDOW, WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO COVER NOW.
WHERE DO THEY FIND THEIR CONTENT
NOW?
I'M SURE, PER USUAL, THEY'LL
JUST FIND OTHER FAKE ANTI-TRUMP
CONSPIRACIES TO PUSH, ALL WHILE
NEVER APOLOGIZING FOR OUTRIGHT
LIES, HYSTERICAL COVERAGE DAY
AFTER DAY, NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
WE'VE BEEN RIGHT ALL ALONG.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
VINDICATED, BUT SO MUCH DAMAGE
HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE.
WE NOW HAVE OUR PARTISAN
TWO-TIERED SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
THAT WE'VE BEEN WARNING YOU
ABOUT.
WE HAVE WATCHED CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS TRAMPLED ON, THE
CONSTITUTION SHREDDED, THE RULE
OF LAW, EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE
LAW, EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS IS TODAY A JOKE, ONE THAT
WILL HAVE A LONGSTANDING IMPACT
ON THIS COUNTRY AND OUR FUTURE.
AND THE BIG QUESTION TONIGHT IS,
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE?
WHAT ABOUT ALL THE LAWS THAT WE
KNOW HAVE BEEN BROKEN WITH REAL
EVIDENCE?
BECAUSE UP UNTIL NOW, MANY
DEMOCRATS, ALL THESE DEEP STATE
OPERATIVES THAT HAVE ABUSED
POWER AND CONSPIRED AGAINST
TRUMP AND BEEN INVOLVED IN
CONSPIRACIES, YEAH, THEY'VE
GOTTEN A FREE PASS.
MUELLER SPENT 22 MONTHS
INVESTIGATING PRESIDENT TRUMP
OVER WHAT WAS A FANTASY BASED ON
NO EVIDENCE.
MEANWHILE, WE HAVE FOR TWO YEARS
ON THIS PROGRAM PRESENTED REAL
ACTUAL RUSSIAN CAMPAIGN
COLLUSION IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL IN HISTORY.
WE HAVE REAL COLLUSION WITH REAL
EVIDENCE.
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER WAS LITERALLY PUT
TOGETHER BY A FOREIGN SPY,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE USED REAL RUSSIAN LIES, YEAH,
FROM RUSSIA.
WHY WAS THAT NOT INVESTIGATED?
WHY ARE WE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THAT TONIGHT?
THAT DIRTY CLINTON RUSSIAN
DOSSIER WHICH WAS NEVER VERIFIED
AND WE NOW KNOW UNVERIFIABLE
BECAUSE THE AUTHOR CAN'T STAND
BY IT.
USED TO SPY ON A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE.
AND WE KNOW REPORTERS WERE FED
AND SPREAD THOSE RUSSIAN LIES,
BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION, THAT
INCLUDES THE WASHINGTON POST.
WE KNOW FISA COURT JUDGES, THAT
THEY WERE LIED TO, FRAUDS
COMMITTED BEFORE THEM.
THEY WERE NEVER TOLD ABOUT THE
DOSSIER'S AUTHOR, HATING TRUMP.
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR IT.
THEY WERE NEVER TOLD THAT NONE
OF THAT NONE OF THIS WAS
VERIFIED OR CORROBORATED.
WHY WAS CARTER PAGE IN THE
MIDDLE OF ALL OF THIS, BASED ON
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN LIES?
WHY WAS THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN SPIED
ON BECAUSE OF CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES?
WHY HAS THAT NOT BEEN
INVESTIGATED?
AND WE KNOW A HIGH-RANKING
UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL TRIED TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON GET ELECTED,
INTERFERE IN OUR ELECTION.
THEY DID IT BY TIMING THE
RELEASE OF EMBARRASSING MATERIAL
ABOUT THEN-CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN
PAUL MANAFORT.
THEY CALLED IT AN ILLEGAL
INTRUSION INTO THE AMERICAN
ELECTION CAMPAIGN.
WHY WAS THAT NOT INVESTIGATED BY
MUELLER?
WHAT ABOUT THE URANIUM ONE
SCANDAL?
WHAT ABOUT PUTIN HAVING THUGS
RIGHT HERE IN AMERICA, THAT WE
KNOW WERE INVOLVED IN BRIBERY,
EXTORTION, KICKBACKS, MONEY
LAUNDERING?
WE HAD AN AMERICAN FBI SPY
INSIDE PUTIN'S NETWORK TELLING
AMERICAN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PUTIN WANTED A FOOTHOLD AND HE
GOT IT.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH EWE  --
URANIUM.
WHAT ABOUT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION?
THEY TOOK $145 MILLION.
THAT WAS HILLARY CLINTON SIGNING
OFF ON IT.
HER HUSBAND MEETING WITH PUTIN
IN RUSSIA.
WHY WAS THAT NOT INVESTIGATED?
WHY WERE THERE, WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS, NO CRIMINAL
REFERRALS FOR THOSE ASSOCIATED
WITH CLINTON?
OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
NONE OF THAT WAS INVESTIGATED
BECAUSE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION WAS A PARTISAN
WITCH-HUNT FROM DAY ONE.
REMEMBER, AFTER ALL, MUELLER
HIRED A TEAM FILLED WITH
BIG-TIME CLINTON, OBAMA-LOVING,
TRUMP-HATING DONORS.
LITERALLY HILLARY CLINTON'S
LAWYER AT THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
HOW IN GOOD CONSCIENCE DID SHE
EVER GET HIRED BY MUELLER?
WHY WAS MUELLER'S PIT BULL, HIS
TOP PROSECUTOR ANDREW WEISSMAN,
A GUY WHO ATTENDED HILLARY
CLINTON'S VICTORY PARTY THAT
NEVER TRANSPIRED.
HE WAS A TOP INVESTIGATOR FOR
MUELLER.
AND STRZOK WAS INVOLVED FROM THE
GET-GO.
HE WAS THE ONE THAT WAS CALLING
TRUMP SUPPORTERS SMELLY WALMART
SHOPPERS, SAYING THAT HILLARY
CLINTON SHOULD WIN 100 MILLION
TO 0.
HE REFERRED TO TRUMP AS A
DEPLORABLE HUMAN BEING.
HE SAW THE RUSSIA PROBE AS AN
INSURANCE POLICY TO STOP TRUMP
IN CASE HE WINS.
AND DON'T FORGET HOW THEY RIGGED
-- HE WAS THE ONE THAT
INTERVIEWED HILLARY CLINTON IN
HER INVESTIGATION AND HE WAS
WRITING HER EXONERATION IN MAY
OF 2016 BEFORE THEY DID THE
INVESTIGATION IN JULY.
AND HE INTERVIEWED HILLARY ON
JULY 2ND.
AND THEN THEY STARTED
INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE BIGGEST SLAM
DUNK OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CASE
EVER?
IF I HAD SUBPOENAED 33,000
EMAILS, I DELETE THEM, ACID WASH
MY HARD DRIVE, AND THEN BUST UP
MY DEVICES WITH HAMMERS, AND
REMOVE SIM CARDS, I THINK I
WOULD BE IN JAIL FOR A LONG
TIME.
WE HAD CLASSIFIED TOP-SECRET
INFORMATION ON HILLARY'S SERVER.
YEAH, INCLUDING HILLARY.
AND MUELLER HIRED ZERO, ZIP
REGISTERED REPUBLICANS.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT MAYBE
OVER THE WEEKEND, MAYBE NEXT
WEEK, SOMETIME SOON, THIS
MUELLER REPORT, IS INEVITABLY,
AT LEAST THE CONTENTS OF IT, TO
THE EXTENT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
DECIDES, WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT
AS MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN ABOUT
WHAT'S IN THERE.
BUT KNOW THIS.
THIS IS ONLY -- WHATEVER IT IS,
IT'S ONLY ONE SIDE OF THE STORY.
WHATEVER YOU HEAR IS ONLY THE
PROSECUTORIAL VIEWPOINT, THOSE
ALWAYS HELLBENT ON BLUDGEONING
THIS PRESIDENT, NO MATTER WHAT.
TONIGHT, WE KNOW THAT MUELLER
DID NOT INDICT DONALD TRUMP JR
OR JARED KUSHNER OR OTHER PEOPLE
SUBJECT TO THE INSANE MEDIA
HYSTERIA SPECULATION.
IS THE MEDIA EVER GOING TO
APOLOGIZE TO THEM?
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
AND WE KNOW MUELLER DID NOT
CHARGE ANYONE IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, NOBODY, AND WILL NOT,
FOR CONSPIREING WITH RUSSIA TO
FIX THE 2016 ELECTION.
WE KNOW THAT MUELLER NEVER
SUSPEND THE PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT
FIRE MUELLER, AS MANY PREDICTED
HE WOULD.
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
INTERFERE WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
THIS WAS AN INVESTIGATION INTO
COLLUSION, IF THERE'S NO
COLLUSION OR CONSPIRACY WAS
FOUND, NOTHING ELSE MATTERS, NO
MATTER WHAT THESE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN SELLING YOU LIES FOR
YEARS TELL YOU.
BUT WE MUST NOT FORGET WHAT
HAPPENED.
A PARTISAN WITCH-HUNT, RIG THAT
ELECTION WHEN SHE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN INDICTED.
THEY DIDN'T WANT DONALD TRUMP TO
WIN.
SO THEN THEY LIED AND COMMITTED
FRAUD BEFORE A FISA COURT,
DENYING A FELLOW CITIZEN THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, SPYING ON
AN OPPOSITIONAL PARTY CANDIDATE
IN AN ELECTION YEAR, HAVING IT
LEAKED TO AMERICAN PEOPLE,
RUSSIAN LIES TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION, AND THEN OF COURSE
TELLING DONALD TRUMP COMEY DID
IT.
HE SIGNS ONTO THE FISA
APPLICATION IN 2016.
IN 2017 HE SAID IT'S UNVERIFIED
AND SALACIOUS.
THAT'S WHAT HE TOLD THE FISA
COURT.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE FISA COURT
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HATED TRUMP.
THIS CANNOT HAPPEN IF WE WANT TO
REMAIN A CONSTITUTIONAL REP --
REPUBLIC.
WHERE WE GO FROM HERE TONIGHT
MATTERS.
ALL OF THOSE THAT ABUSE THEIR
POWER, THAT DID EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER, THAT WE GRANT THEM,
WE GIVE TO THEM, TO FIRST STOP
DONALD TRUMP FROM EVER BEING
ELECTED, AND THEN HAVING AN
INSURANCE POLICY IF HE WAS
ELECTED, THINKING THEY KNEW
BETTER THAN YOU, WE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER
THAN ALL OF US.
THEY ALL NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
FROM THIS DAY ON.
IN THE DAYS, THE WEEKS, THE
MONTHS AHEAD.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU AND THE
MEDIA, I PROMISE YOU, YOU WILL